welcome back to cbs mornings on our
eight o'clock hour award-winning
journalist anderson cooper is in the
house investigating his hello hello
investigating his influential roots do
you like your influence yes yes this is
surreal
well yeah no it's the ancestral home
one day we'll have you up there anderson
he's a great great great great great
great three greats grandson of cornelius
vanderbilt a legend from america's
gilded age vanderbilt created a railroad
and a shipping empire that made him the
wealthiest man in america how rich
at one point this family had more money
than the u.s treasury 150 years ago wow
in his new book vanderbilt the rise and
fall of an american dynasty anderson
cooper digs into his family's lineage
we'll talk with him about that in just a
moment but first a look back at the
vanderbilt lives
the bulk of the vanderbilt fortune came
from railroads the family owned tracks
from new york to chicago
dubbed the commodore cornelius
vanderbilt began his career in shipping
with a 100 family loan
by his death he was the richest man in
america amassing 100 million dollars
that's the equivalent of more than 2
billion today his son billy expanded the
family business doubling the vanderbilt
fortune with lavish homes across the
east coast the vanderbilts became
american royalty with a high social
standing but the third and fourth
generations had more of a knack for
spending money than making it
bad business decisions and the decline
of the railroad industry led the family
to lose most of their fortune
many of the mansions were torn down or
turned into museums the dynasty ended
with eris turned fashion designer gloria
vanderbilt
after her death in 2019 her son anderson
cooper sorted through troves of letters
documents and journals
giving voice to the vanderbilt ancestors
he never knew
journalists author and 60 minutes
contributor anderson cooper joins us now
in the studio anderson good to see you
okay this was my reading over the
weekend they'll give me a call yesterday
what a story book
what a story you have to tell you say
your family's messy insecure complicated
but always fascinating you also say in
the book that this was not a story you
talk about my ancestors by the way not
not like my cousins were watching right
now that's that's why i use the word
they're not
anderson
but you said that this was a book you
never intended to write because you've
always spent your life trying to
distance yourself from the advantage i
mean growing up i never really wanted to
be associated with that i didn't want
that name has comes with a lot of kind
of preconce you know preconceived
notions and you didn't want to be
associated with money
not really no i mean i wanted to no
not because i think the the idea was
that people kind of thought well i must
have a huge amount of money and and you
know have some sort of a trust fund
which wasn't the case and so i didn't
want that being how people saw me when i
walked into a room so i was very glad my
last name was cooper and i really chose
not to even i really didn't even know
much about the vanderbilts uh until
really going to research
that fact about the trust fund is one of
the most astounding in the book and
really frames the book this was the
richest family in america uh
a family so rich that had more money
than the u.s government than the
treasury
and then loses it all effectively by the
time your mother's a little girl um what
stood out to you in the lessons
contained in all of that i mean to me
what was interesting about this is how
you know this man commodore vanderbilt
made this huge fortune
and had a real pathology about money i
mean all it was all he cared about he
didn't care about his daughters because
they wouldn't inherit the vanderbilt
name he was
you know cunning and ruthless and a
genius for making money uh but kind of
the ripple effects of that money over
the the generations and kind of the how
the pathology his pathology about money
how it kind of infected subsequent
generations for me with the lesson was
always you know just keep working like
work hard not don't be a layabout that
was your lesson that was my lesson i
took away early on now reading about the
opulence and the wealth and the status
along with the issues i couldn't help
but to draw comparisons to
social media of today people present
this image um and they want us to all
understand that their life is grand
right but behind the scenes things could
be falling apart falling apart um i feel
like the vanderbilts could serve as a
cautionary tale yeah for a lot of us i
think yeah i mean they certainly were
for me and and i think you know you look
at their lives and you know look
they they were living huge lavish lives
a lot of them were miserable and you
know the one woman essentially sold off
her daughter into a loveless marriage
with a british you know duke so that
they could get a title and social status
based on that and that obviously didn't
last very long um but i do think in in
many ways it's a cautionary tale you
know i wrote the book really kind of as
a letter to my son because i when i had
a kid i realized
i don't really know what i'm going to
tell them about the vanderbilts because
i never wanted to even look closely at
them i mean i went out of my way to
avoid mentioning to anybody when i first
met them you know and i always kind of
dreaded the moment somebody would say oh
hey i heard your mom's gloria vanderbolt
what was it like to grow up a vanderbilt
and uh you know i never really knew how
to answer that question because i grew
up a cooper and that's what i was very
happy but i was so fascinated that you
got to really dig into your mom's stuff
number one your mom saved so many things
my mom saved everything everything yeah
i've been going through her stuff for
like my mom had the storage unit which
was like the storage unit from citizen
kane at the end where they're just like
right or like raiders the lost ark when
they're wheeling the ark into that huge
storage unit i've been going through it
for like 15 years and you'd open up one
box and it's you know it's like a really
nice i don't know vase and then you open
another box and it's corn flakes from
1953
they've been packed away as you read
about them did they come alive to you
did you like them what did you think
yeah i mean you know what's really what
really came a lot to me is when i
started going through stuff my mom had
in her apartment in boxes and she had
all these letters that that were from
her aunt gertrude vanderbilt whitney who
founded the whitney museum and all these
characters these people who
whose voices i'd never really heard and
to suddenly hear them in the in these
letters it brought them alive in a very
human way and this isn't a book about
you know the business achievements of
commodore vanderbilt great books have
been written about that
this is really about how these human
beings at key moments in their life how
they responded to the events around them
that from the outside to your point you
know looked very grand and amazing you
know the wedding of this young beautiful
woman to a british duke uh it was a huge
event in in america but she was
miserable and crying all the way to the
altar or the one woman who admitted that
she liked abusing slaves i don't care
for her
well that's that's a woman elva who
married uh my great uncle yeah and uh
she had grown up in the confederate
south and her family feminists yeah and
then later in life became yeah a funder
of the feminist movement and and even
for people of color
promoting you know the right to vote for
women uh but yeah she was a terrible
still didn't care for her anderson but i
know what she was when he said something
about wyatt tony well yeah why well yeah
i mean so it's often said to understand
is to forgive and to accept you you were
uh agnostic at best when it came to the
vanderbilt side of your family you wrote
this book before wyatt your one-year-old
very cute brother who was one of the
most beautiful boys
on the planet other than teddy please
put up white
other than teddy there you get a tight
having written this book
for that beautiful boy right there do
you feel better prouder different about
being a vanderbilt and and for him to
have a vanderbilt legacy as well i think
they were they were far more no that was
just a happy day
that was that was his first balloon so
that was the big present you know i feel
like um i want him to
understand who these people were that
that are in his you know in a small way
in his very
distant past and i also want him to take
the lessons away from that i took from
this family and also know that that may
be in his past but it's not his future
and his future is his own to write like
i know we gotta go because megan is
saying wrap it up but you've got a great
story in the book well written about
when your mom was selling off her art
you pretended to be your assistant named
mom
she yeah i got my mom on instagram
because she was sort of was you know not
feeling good right about her life and
wasn't getting out of bed monica voice
anderson no i didn't talk to anybody on
the phone so yeah so but we needed
somebody to like manage her instagram
account and like deal with people who
were buying her paintings and i the only
person like she was like you have to do
it i was like me i like i got three jobs
he was monica so she was like you should
be an assistant named monica and like be
a lady of a certain age and just deal
with people so that's what i did well
like i'd be in iraq and in my spare time
i'd be like do you want that framed or
yeah we're being we're being screamed
out here to go but i will halloween is
coming up you've written a book about
the commodore will we see the pork chops
in your halloween costume will you be
the commodore no i'll tell you what uh
the guy who the cover chip kid who's an
old friend of my mom's and mine uh he
gave me his childhood batman costume
that his mom made for him in the 60s so
that's going to be my son's costume
thank you i'm talking about your costume
i don't know the producer megan is
saying tell anderson to stop talking we
have to we gotta go
but anderson thank you for the
transparency really really great this is
well done mom and this is her mom that's
been bug and gail all weekend it has
been bugging me because i think you
should say these people are anderson i
like the mystery all right we're getting
there we're getting the vanderbilt goes
on sale tomorrow wherever you like to
buy your books and on today's cbs
morning podcast anderson tells vlad what
he was most surprised to learn about his
family history